are you in a bookshop or is that just
your library
that's my library
awesome
so
were you guys familiar with the original
film before you came on to this version
um i i had heard of it i had not watched
it and um
first i read the script
uh which
led me to a conversation with matt sobel
um which i found
you know he was wildly intelligent
um then i went
to um
watch the original and you know i was
really wrestling with the idea because
you know
why do we remake this movie that one was
pretty darn good and
um which is both a reason to remake it
and not remake it um
you know given that it hadn't reached
american audiences but i have done a
handful of remakes as you may know um
and um yeah i think just the curiosity
of playing this role
with those kind of constrictions and
limitations and also the thriller aspect
the psychological piece of you know
what it is to um be a mother in this
time in her life and who's battling all
these demons and
um needing to show up for her children
but in
and not doing the best job of of it um
and not communicating well
um it felt
it felt
like a a decent enough challenge for me
to want to go through with it and matt
felt like i was i felt like i was in
trusted hands with him
and what about you boys did you were you
familiar with the film
um
we actually we were told by matt um our
director not to
watch the film um
so we hadn't seen the original film
going into this
like
you knew about it yes i i knew about the
film i was familiar about the fact that
when we first got the audition
you remember you were like yes
i knew about the film um when we got the
audition i was very like oh i've like i
know about this film and you know
this like this is a scary movie you know
getting to remake it this would be fun
um
so i hadn't seen it though prior to that
and then when we got the role i we were
told not to watch it so i was like okay
um
and then yeah we didn't know really what
would happen at the end because we had a
specific point in the script to where it
just stopped and it didn't go past that
so we didn't know the ending wow
so it wouldn't like
so it wouldn't affect like our
performance like because like if we knew
the ending it would like while filming
it it might have changed how we like our
perspective on it so it would change how
like our acting exactly so
when we did find out the ending
um we were about to shoot the ending so
it was like we found out um
very soon before we actually shot it so
all those emotions um
and like just finding out what happens
it was all very fresh when we shot it um
which really just made for
a great ending okay
they're telling me i have to rap out
already so
um
thank you so much guys it was really
great and uh it was nice talking to you
very very briefly
five